this is the third time restrictions have
been increased in the past month
and it comes as the number of daily
infections has continued to rise
what worries the authorities is that
this third wave is far more widespread
than previous surges
and unless the numbers are curbed
hospital resources
could become stretched there is no
center of this wave
for us to focus our prevention measures
this could result in a much larger
spread
if the medical system reaches its limit
it will cause great damage to all of us
there will be tighter controls on
restaurants and indoor gatherings
no spectators at sporting events fifty
percent occupancy on
intercity trains and buses and private
companies are urged to get a third of
their staff
working remotely from home the measures
introduced during this
third wave have resulted in a 20 drop
in the amount that people are traveling
and mingling
just as it did in the second wave over
the summer
but there hasn't been a corresponding
drop in the number of new infections
that's led to further concerns that
people have been finding
ways around these tighter restrictions
and that in a country
known for its high level of public
compliance
even here pandemic fatigue may be
setting in
rob mcbride al jazeera seoul